everybody just needs to not be able to
have sex until the age of 25 and then
when they do they're like look I'm fully
emotionally balanced I've been through a
bunch of breakups but I kind of know
what I like and what I don't like it
blah blah blah describing there is
marriage Chris
that used to be what it was you weren't
allowed to have sex if we got married
which gave like men in particular a
massive incentive to get there together
because if you can't get married until
you've like achieved certain adult
things like you've got a job you've got
a house if you have to get all of your
ducks in a row before you can have sex
that's a huge incentive to behave
yourself and to do pro-social stuff this
may be an argument that